قاعة اللغة الكورية Joo Eung Gi-seo ورئيس مجلس الدولة لجمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية شين
يحتفل الرفيق بـ Kim Seong-eun ، الخادم ، في الثامن من يوليو.
ابحث عن نظارات الرماية Geumsusan 8 واستخدمها
شوربة دايهان الكورية هذه الخطوة الأولى هي الخير الحقيقي لبلدنا
الأب وقائد الحكمة العظيم نيسين ويت إيون ، تنين الماء ، جيم إيلسونغ ، والرفيق العظيم
قصر كومسوسان للشمس ، حيث تتفجر الحياة الأبدية بحفر مجموعات طوعية للانقلاب الشتوي
لقد غمرتني عشرات الآلاف من الأجواء
نعم
[موسيقى]
Mirnuri Umirin Nong متوسط
أستطيع سماع حركة المديح للرفيق كبير الخدم لكل خادم
يتم قياس سلال الملابس
[موسيقى]
اتهمت اللجنة المركزية لحزب العمل جمهورية
جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية تشو 1952
جمهورية الصين الشعبية من التنين التي أصبحت كتاباتي تهدأ
[موسيقى]
أوه ، 40 جرامًا وراء الصديق الذي يقوم بالتنظيم مع سوكيونغ ، الجيل الرابع من أحدث العلوم.
قمة البطيخ من مديان ثقيلة ، فماذا فعلت بالورق المبتكر؟
ذكرت وسائل الإعلام أن الرفيق سونغ ، الذي احتل المرتبة العاشرة في تنين الماء ، والرفيق كيم سيونغ إيل القائد العظيم ، كانا
الآن بما أنك تبحث عن نمط حياة أبدية يطعمك 15 1
عضو فكري وغير عادي